foreign
foreign
okay welcome everybody to the uh
Christmas edition of the infrastructure
and services
committee
eight no eighth of uh sorry 6th of
December
um
firstly I'm going to do apologies I have
one from councilor Germany are there any
others
none can I please have someone move that
thank you Nigel Sega councilor Soper I
put that motion all those in favor
aye thank you
first item is the minutes of the
infrastructure committee meeting held on
the 8th of November that they be
received
moved Ms cook seconded
Ms coot I'll put that all those in favor
thank you for that it's okay for the
police where it's monitored well we're
working through that we'll own the
hardware it's not the liability is once
you get the information what you do with
it that the policy that's where the
restrictions need to be on who can
access once you've got it not allowance
necessarily the hard way that it gets to
the wherever the monitoring agency is
okay Tom
the the issue of privacy
I must concern is the wrong word but I
think I just think it's something that
we we do need to think carefully about
and therefore when I I look at a
stakeholder group
um I just wonder who is it's you know
thinking about that issue
and and it might be that it's two
councilors that are on it that should be
doing so
um but I think somebody has to be
particularly thinking about that rather
normally thinking about the security
aspect of it I think one of the things
about CCTV it seems to me not only you
know how how where do you put it but
also how far do you go because you could
end up with you know CC's TV you know on
every street corner on every
um you know like they do in London
um so anyway I I just wanted to ask that
question about you know who is
representing the um that privacy issue
in a stakeholder committee should there
be somebody specifically for that or is
it as a enough that you know councilors
the counselor's skeleton are on that
committee will look after that issue
history through you Mr chair so
counselor Campbell that the Privacy
um component and for a CCTV policy is
overseen by council's privacy officer
Andrew Cameron so that's something we
deal with operationally the stakeholder
committees and is about the engagement
to say where would we place the cameras
uh in the central visit business
district area so it all stemmed from uh
the equipment needing to be upgraded so
where the policy the policy side sits
operationally with us as staff so we
have that oversight and obligation
right Evelyn and then Peter
um
most of the people on this committee
actually have use or experience with
um some form of CCTV in their business
and for and things already so they would
be well aware it's not solely incumbent
on the councilors but I'm reassured to
hear that
our internal legal team are also part of
that because that makes us I just have a
question about I know we're looking at
the inner city at the moment but part of
the request was wider than that
as part of forward planning do we need
to think about the issues that were
raised by that wider request
um look if you're talking about the
placement of cameras
also the type of information that was
being sought which rather than being
um
people focused was more vehicle focused
all you have with with so I can speak to
this treaty is that with with the camera
technology today you have artificial
intelligence in the cameras and to what
extent you use that intelligence for is
is really up to us but the simplest one
is NPR which is number plate recognition
and that is invaluable for police for
Crime for for everything it just makes
sense it's a no-brainer if you know if
you want to find a number plate where a
car is who is doing it that's fine so
that I guess every time you use a piece
of that artificial intelligence then
you're getting into privacy and you
would need to be upfront on what parts
you are using so for example
hypothetically if you were going to use
face recognition to track someone then
that would create a different a a
different thing so at the moment that is
still all in the work being done by
Scott Bain
and that'll come to Council of what a
system can do it's really how we use it
I think
um we'll we'll answer those questions
oh thank you Mr T that's quite
clarifying because I probably
and I might not be the only one was
thinking more about the face recognition
technology or the people recognition
technology rather than the number plate
recognition so thank you for clarifying
that it possibly will do both oh yeah
yeah thank you Peter yeah thank you L5
do the cameras cover not the distance
the actual cameras but which area of the
CBD do they go out no that is that is
still to come without a story come and
and uh Mr Bain who truly talked about is
working on that exact thing a lot a lot
of it will be determined by uh the
access to to either fiber and power
power is the critical one and a lot of
cities around New Zealand there is
permanent power to lighting poles uh not
an invercargill
um that that's right isn't it Russell
yeah so things like traffic lights uh
will have to be the source of power
potentially for 24 7 power
um so all this has to be worked out yet
and then once that is you then look
apply that to the budget
so you first bit CBD and then you can
potentially spread out to Windsor's
South City uh the North Road entrance
the East entrance at the cemetery you
can look at all different parts after
that but our first protocol is that you
know what we talked about with making
this a safe CBD thank you the second
part of the question is of the 250 000
is that uh paid solely by the commercial
rate payers or is it on the general rate
does everyone pay for it now this is a
budget that comes out of General rates
thank you yep further questions Nigel I
thank you for your chair just um to
clarify having had a couple of
conversations with Mr Bain I think that
report will be quite conclusive in the
sense of the way forward uh pre-december
treat us my understanding but regarding
policy which we were talking about just
um certainly happy to help if there's
any because obviously we've got a very
large Network
um at the stadium but have any
assistance needed there's some policy
there that we could grab or have a look
at going forward but I understand that
report will be pretty conclusive on so
that's coming to us in March yeah uh Mr
Mayor did you have your hand up again
yeah just just one last issue with the
capacity to uh to add to the network
so and who makes the decision on some of
those things I've had recently some
feedback from
the campaign Association that's got the
park down by stead Bridge stead Street
Wharf and we've had that building tagged
a couple of three times recently that
we've had to do you know is a a one-off
location like that potentially added at
some later stage if we wanted to at the
moment we've got people parking there
because I don't want to delve into
details no I'm just saying yeah it can
be so you would probably start off with
the server system that would take a
minimum of 250 500 cameras but the key
thing
that Scott needs to work out for us is
the network that you connect into that's
the tough bit
um that's the that's a real tricky bit
and could consume a fair part of the the
budget rather than the cameras yeah
okay thank you okay any further
questions
um we've got some recommendations here
um
that we receive the report
and note that the next progress report
will be in March next year and also we
recommend to council that council is
SOPA and skelt remain on the stakeholder
group if that's happy with both those
I'll move yeah yeah yeah start sorry I'm
just checking with cancer thank you
that's okay
um right that's moved by Evelyn seconded
by
Trish I'll put that marginalized in
favor
aye that's carried
thanks Trudy
right now for the this was really
interesting reading
welcome Russell
transport procurement strategy that
we're sending to um
and I see you referred to me
um
does the chair have to
authorize this one
no Mr chair this this report's about the
um National and transport strategy so
it's the following one of the activity
report
okay so this is one of my um
key strategies for transport and I guess
in the past it used to be called the
writing procurement strategy but because
it includes
um both our roads and our public
transport
um options that spend now terminalized
as a transport
this strategy looks to sit alongside and
complement Council strategy but it is
something that we need to do
specifically for a requirement for
walkatahi to actually continue to gain
their subsidy so from my perspective
it's a pretty important strategy and
it's been something we've been working
on
um certainly this strategy has changed a
little bit and it has certainly got a
some other elements added to better
outcomes which is a government
initiative that you may have ridden
through there which is something that
the government requires of their
department but a recommendation to
councils but once again their funding
becomes I guess linked to that
you might also have noted in the
strategy that or the draft strategy that
it is refers to a number of our future
contracts which include their
maintenance a road maintenance contract
which is about which is coming up for
Renewal and that talks about I guess an
approach of a shared risk which is more
of an alliance style contract happy to
answer any questions on the strategy
right Tom
uh I mean I read every word and digested
some
um so maybe the um the obvious question
is is there anything that's different
than this from what has traditionally
occurred
I know it's understand it's a new
strategy so there's nothing to compare
it with but
um yeah is there any innocence different
I guess the elements that are that that
have been added to it are around where
we hid with better outcomes and I guess
that is the government initiative
and we are proposing to continue to use
the shared risk model which is what I
talked about in terms of the maintenance
contract is probably our biggest
um five plus one plus one so it's a
seven year contract and that encompasses
most of the roading works I guess that
is more of an alliance style which is
currently what we're operating under so
but it is of a relatively similar nature
to our historical
strategies and it is relatively
consistent with
many other councils thank you
um Russell a question around
this is the amount of money allocated uh
for unsealed road maintenance is that is
that enough 300 000.
the numbers that are included in the in
the strategy are the amount that we have
um been allocated and applied for
through our budgeting process through
the national land transport we have
two elements to our unsealed road
maintenance which is our maintenance
head routine maintenance which is our
grading but we also have other money
allocated which is our
re-mettling was which we where we go out
there and we add new I guess what we
would call a running course on top of it
around around our Network as and where
it's needed so
um
the more you want to do the more it
costs so I guess we try to find that
balance and that's our numbers are
similar to what we've been traditionally
using right right even though there may
be more wear and tear on those rates
because of
um sort of semi-rural sort of
development along these roads with all
you know obviously more traffic
movements potentially uh might be a new
dairy farm there or something with milk
tankers
the challenges we face with all of our
unsealed roads along with our roads is
to actually try to find that sweet spot
in the maintenance and renewal phase and
it's the type of material that you will
apply and we are trialing I guess a
number of different types of
metals on some of our roads and how we
do them that the frequency of grading
just to try to find that Optimum place
that
keeps
our customers as happy as we can okay
there's a Alex
um thank you Mr chair um does that
include um I know we've spoken about
before with um unsealed roads in um
residence complaining especially in the
peak summer seasons about dust does that
include the oiling and maintenance in
that manner
very good question unfortunately some
three to four years ago environment
Southland
required anybody who was applying a
product on the roads to have a have a
consent and they had a transition period
so at the moment to my knowledge there's
no products that are approved for dust
suppressant
um in the past it's fair to say that our
versions of oil were used but they now
are now no longer in approved so there
are other products that are out there
which are some are wood based but some
of them have to be applied quite
frequently and their tenure or the the
period they work is quite low and that
that costs that we currently ask the
people who benefited from the residents
to actually fund themselves so we would
have a an approved contractor who can go
out there and apply and approved product
so long as they've got a resource
consent So currently I'm unaware of
anybody who has a product that is widely
in use
following on from there
question
these rural semi-rural houses collect
rainwater for their drinking water off
their roofs and obviously dust on the
roof is not good so is there a certain
distance and probably Trudy may be able
to answer this that a house can be built
close to a gravel road you know where
the dust is there any such thing
respectful I'm going to offer that to
treaty but that's a planning issue and
Duck and Dodge
um not for a particular Gravel Road
there will be four against a road but it
doesn't specify for gravel is my
understanding but I may be wrong I'll
need to double check with the planning
team okay and I was just curious about
that because obviously that concern of
Alex's is you know the dust getting out
of the house and and everything yeah any
further questions regarding Tom
yeah I'm sorry I'm in Tesco the first
time I got a chance
um the table one
um number 723 street lights
for the NES contract according to this
was run out in the 30th of June this
year
um so what's taking its place I cannot
find anything
it's a very good question we currently
operate that
um under our road maintenance we've just
absorbed that it's a reasonably small
contract and we'll when we tender
post-christmas we'll be also having the
street lights maintenance in that
contract we have to remember that we
changed all of our street lights to LEDs
three years ago and as such
um
the
type of work they do is response work at
the moment that's typically we only are
going to our street lights when someone
unfortunately hits them
um so in the past you used to have to
race around and change the lamps every
12 000 hours which is every three to
four years so now that's reduced
significantly so it's a relatively small
amount of work so we've just been
getting done correct yeah thank you
Leslie
thank you Mr chair it's not a question
it's just a comment that I'm really
pleased to see again that we've got
value includes considerations not solely
focused on price for instance what
benefit the procure procurement could
bring to the local community or
environment I'm just really pleased to
see that
we've again got that in the policy
because I think it's a really good
signal about our procurement and just
the other comment Russell
um and I suppose like Tom approves I've
read it
um in the executive summary could you
change the spelling of the word
principle please
certainly thank you
okay further questions no
so did you just just to clarify at the
moment this is with wakakotahi they are
um reading it as well and they have
their uh markipin out and have
highlighted a couple of versions before
it's got to the um to this report and it
will it could easily have some other
minor tweaks on the way past
um they have the land transport act they
have to make it comply with so they're
quite thorough in their assessment of it
so I will be bringing back a version
that they will have endorsed for
council's consideration right well that
brings us on to the recommendations
which are receiving the report and also
um
sending this to council if wakakatahi do
endorse it you move move those
recommendations seconded councilor scalp
put that motion all those in favor aye
against that scary thank you
takes us now to the road stopping
and I believe is Heather here
but we're not going to discuss this
topic is that correct Mr chair that's we
would like that well that report to be
withdrawn we have identified we have an
error and I guess the process that we
believe is best
um we start again and we'll bring a
report through okay I can I can actually
just put that on hold can I yep that's
fine okay that takes us next to
the activities report and uh it's
reasonably diverse speed reviews already
Beach entrance Steve Street Road Works
transport Network bus fares wasting it
joint agreement and storm water
Russell most of those are yours
so thanks Mr chairman um
I guess there's quite a range of topics
on there and happy to receive
questions on it but probably there's a
there's a couple that are well worth
having a conversation on you'll see that
there's quite a bit on speed and um
although that we've we've been quite
forward and they're thinking of changing
some of our speed limits I guess it's
worth noting that we there was a
unfortunately a recent crash on our
Network and we believe that the
reduction in speed
um due to what what has occurred from
100K to 80k's is probably
reduced the severity of that crash quite
significantly
um it was a I guess what I would
describe as a T-bone crash and it could
have been uh much much much more serious
and I'm but I think that just highlights
um the faster we go the worse the the
worse the mess if something goes wrong
and I guess that's probably all that's
sad for it to occur it probably means
that we haven't um we've actually been
quite successful so that's speed
certainly the second one I'd just like
to point out is the community connect
um
and I guess it's really worth
remembering that of as of the 1st of
February our current fears on our
passenger transport are have been
reduced by subsidy from the government
and that comes off in the first of
February but from then people who have a
community services card who have
registered come into and or gone online
when the forms are up will come into
Council we'll get a
um
an endorsement on the on their um
B card which will give them once again a
50 fear reduction so that's something
that's something's coming off and
something's coming on but that's from
the 1st of February so it's actually
quite an important
his piece of Community Information
that's out there so okay well take
questions on those just those topics so
far uh Evelyn
yes
yes to Pearson
I was a little confused about this does
that mean that this will be all gay
rather than just the nine to three and
that's why people who have a gold card
should choose
um which option they they
[Music]
um
load onto the card because I couldn't
quite see if it if it's only nine till
three I couldn't see what the the
relevance of saying you have to choose
one or the other
thank you it's a really excellent
question to highlight it so if you if
you hold a
super gold card you get free travel
between the hours of nine and three so
so you
you travel for
um zero dollars if you have a community
services card you can travel any time of
the day but you only get a 50 reduction
so if you happen to be have a super gold
and a community card you either have to
effectively have two cards and choose
which one you want to use or you choose
one of the two so clearly if you're
traveling between the hours of nine and
three you will always use your super
gold concession loaded but the the key
thing is you can only load one
concession on one card but many people
in our community have access to the
Community Services cards so for them
they will obviously need to register
that card as a concession against their
B card and therefore use it
um for that 50 to get access to that 50
reduction so I agree it's a little bit
confusing and at the moment across the
country the comms messages just really
waiting to get out there and actually
bring this message forward
um
I don't often use my Community my super
gold outs and be card outside of
um
you know those hours but my recollection
is that that's 50 percent
um Supergirl cars free travel
outside of the nine or three no sorry
outside of nine to three it's full price
it's full price which is um two dollars
or two dollars a trip which is probably
one of the best fares in New Zealand
indeed thank you uh Mr Pearson I
appreciate it Mr Mayor and then Leslie
sorry
I mean um just on the issue of Transport
um I noticed in here you've got some
criteria around schools on state
highways
so two issues with that when you say 60
30 variable speed what is the variable
speed mean to an a person
very good question thanks for the
question what it says is that the speed
is that's the 60 is the resident speed
and then at the normal speed and during
the times where the variable speed is
activated which will be that
um
8 15 or 8 20 till nine o'clock when the
kids are coming in and out of school
then that speed is reduced to 30 K's
which is which will be the standard it
is the
on the busy roads it'll be the
um the flashing with the red
reflector red LED sign that's there but
on some of the side roads we'll have the
you'll have seen them in the yellow
signs that say between the hours of
8 30 to 9 or whatever the hours uh that
that speed is 30 kilometers an hour so
that's
so just a second request into that one
um so what happens on schools I'm just
thinking about it when they have big
event days
we have the ability to flash the signs
for a longer period
I would need to check but I would
believe we
to actually identify a different period
because the legislation allows us to
specify the times and just the last
question for us are the ones that you're
recommending in here which are the based
on the state highways are they are they
now compatible what you would internally
with ICC for the other schools
um so there's there's two things going
on here the state highway stuff is stuff
that sites that we can't
um we're not funding or putting in place
but we wish to actually submit and
encourage the wakite to actually get on
and do those schools because it'll be a
disappointment to it for us to um have
done all of our schools and they haven't
done the state highways which are some
of our busier roads so if we need to
encourage them to do that but it's um
but also our schools are the ones we've
picked out of the the highest yeah what
I'm saying is that there are other
schools other than the ones you've
listed there
uh you've listed six there so so the
other schools already at that limit that
then 50 30 or 60 30 or whatever it is
number two we're actually just about to
start this over the next I think I think
we're obliged to do 60 60 of the schools
by June 2024 but we have uh more day
funding for us to do that in advance so
we have some signs we'll put those up
straight after and when and if you
recall when we started through the bylaw
changes last year on speed which has now
been trained changed to the National
speed limit register that requires us to
specify a date when we go live so
business is actually effectively a speed
limit change so hence you'll see these
as we roll the next bunch of schools out
we'll say from this date that's the
speed so
um we just need to make sure that um our
colleagues the police
um are able to enforce speeds should
they need it what I was trying to get to
though is Walker Kota you're driving
these six schools because they're on
National highways stay always well the
hours when we roll ours out be the same
sort of speed limits or will there be
some variation the first three are State
highways and the the other three are our
schools and we can certainly bring back
a list of I think the 24 schools we've
got to do so yeah okay thank you okay
next is Leslie
thanks Mr chair Russell just going back
to the community
um because of the potential for
confusion did you indicate we are
waiting for some Nationwide advertising
or have we already got a communication
strategy locally ready to go on it
that's another great question the answer
to that is yes we have both there is a
national strategy coming out and we have
some comms that we are preparing
ourselves so we can I guess localize
that messaging because the time period
post Christmas for people to get that
concession loaded onto their card is
reasonably short it also will put some
potential stresses on our Organization
for people to have to come in but also
people can will be able to go online
there's currently some work being done
to have a an online registration so yes
we will need lots of comms but we'll
also need to
um have people come and visit us to get
that loaded onto their B card which they
will need to have so we're launching our
local comms within the next week 10 days
a week we're trying to align with with
the national National approach because
it's got a bit of extra radio time and
paper time so
okay thanks okay we've got Trish Dean
Tanya I think
I think true
parents speak
Mr chair I think it's 50 kilometers an
hour in the urban areas
currently we
um have been using um the inflation
school zone so they're the ones where
they've got the four Amber lights and
they blink at certain times that was
started as a trial across the country
and you had two choices for you either
had a 40K in some places or you had the
science that we put up which are the
flashing Embers so we for whatever
reason started down that path and this
is a I guess a national direct directive
that actually is saying um you go to a
variable speed and and the speeds that
have been set are 30 kilometers past
Urban schools and I think 60 up to 60
case it's interesting that some of the
rural schools they've been also
requiring them to go to 30 as well so
yeah thank you I was I was aware that
was 40 I just wasn't sure sure it's 20th
there's a bus pass yes
thank you very much
20 is 20 at both directions yes
yes honey I was just really curious just
around with the concessions needed to be
loaded you know by the 31st of January
between 23. how long does how for how
long are we going to have that program
in place I mean
once again a great question that some
that the concession is as long as the
government allows that and that my mind
standing is there is no end date that
concession which means people could
continue to come in I guess it's that
first few days week when they think they
can get there and their car doesn't
actually give them the 50 then they need
to come in to or go online I guess
that's nationally it's a bit of a
problem our problem won't be as great as
Auckland I would imagine and that's why
there is some
um ability to need to be able to connect
to the MSD database where that we're
your community service card number is
stored as and for it to be secure
just a couple of quick reasons in
relation to Street uh State Street
roadworks that you've got there I saw at
the end you've got a statement that says
we will continue to work closely with
our contractors to ensure this level of
disruption has avoided so does that mean
that we'll still have one-way traffic
as you're reselling what does that mean
that we will have some total closures
um
take it when you pause on it I just just
trying to make sure I hit it 100 right
so
um the ceiling of the road will require
a period of time where there will be
traffic Only One Direction the time
um
there will be traffic be able to get
through there in one direction at all
times
and that's only for a relatively short
time while we sell that seal that piece
of road there are other works for
instance the work that a yes and my
understanding having seen the traffic
management plan they continue to manage
to have
um as many lanes as they can safely
which is so are you suggesting one
you're selling a certain area the
traffic flow will just be one way or
will it alternate with lights
at this stage mind standing as it'll be
one way so people will still need to
return through Bay Road and I think that
date is planned after early after
Christmas so that will have the minimum
traffic disruption
Tom
thank you Mr chair
um
when you're a new counselor you you get
to ask questions that you've certainly
been asked you're certain have been
asked a thousand times before by
councilors
um when I look at the already Beach
entrance paragraph and asked that
question last meeting so I appreciate
the fact that there's a you know
description of what happens in here new
um but I mean I do wonder whether a
fortnightly inspection is
is actually sufficient I mean in in my
view
um invercargill is get two absolutely
premium
destinations outside destinations one is
Queen's Park the other one is the beach
or any Beach
um and yet fairly I'll say regularly but
not infrequently you could do indeed and
it's blocked and I I was there I think
it was two or three weeks ago and it was
a day when the when the the lifeguards
whether it Flags out and it was actually
completely blocked because people had
tried to get in and got stuck so nobody
could go off the beach and nobody could
go on the beach
so I I mean my question really as as the
frequency enough is it what we have
always done even if as actually enough
considering the you know the number of
people that use at Eddie Beach me every
day by the way
um with my dog
um considering the number of people who
use it is actually a sufficient
um service
can we do more
um
I might say that was a really good
question I might pause
Mr Nolan is the um looks after
operations and I'm not sure he
wants to answer mine I might answer on
his behalf so
we have traditionally
um
regularly inspected it and I thought
like it or more frequently and certainly
the uh
the maintenance team goes out there more
regularly than that because they just
pop out and have a look exactly but we
don't necessarily like people to get
stuck either however we could increase
the level of service
there is a cost associated with that
happy happy to do more
but you just need to balance what you're
getting because we can clean the sand
out and it be a dry windy day and by the
the following morning it has actually
got quite a build up what we do find is
that
um and we do know the road the sealed
Road only goes
probably two or third into the beach and
then you you are under sand and it
depends on how dry the sand is and how
much it's compacted so what we do find
is that there are some cars that are
clearly unsuitable to go on the beach
plan to do so
and if two cars approach each other one
has to pull off to the side hence they
get stuck and that's where they get
jammed so unless we actually wanted to
physically build a road and maintain it
all the way to the beach which I'm sure
would need a resource consent in a
number of other things we certainly can
continue to do more and try harder and I
accept that but that does come at an
ongoing cost that's an unsubsidized cost
so you should I think if there was you
know it if the increase in
um
attentiveness we're going to cause some
more adventurous and see how much that
would be
um because innocent that we ask is
always going to be have that reply
hasn't it innocent absolutely it's
always going to have that reply so I I'd
rather than just accept that and give up
on it I would like to see what the extra
cost would be
um but it would seem to me that you know
that a weakly inspection would be in
order
um
but I I do not like to see people
trapped in the beach and that is
certainly happening at the moment
certainly happy to pass it entertainment
and I'm pretty confident that the
supervisor is going there reasons me
regularly as well
um our probably our biggest challenge is
certainly the time between Christmas and
New Year is how we actually keep a team
on and that's not saying that we can't
because we have people who are on
standby to actually respond but it's
just trying to find that find the level
the appropriate level of balance that we
actually are comfortable and if we need
more then we will deliver more so
so Russell just
with Tom's question when would be a
suitable time for you to bring back to
this Committee just to what an increased
level of service would look like and you
know the costs that may be involved I
think in reality if we want to do it we
should try to do it more over the summer
period because by the time I bring it
back to a February committee we've
actually just about missed the peak the
horse is bolted as you might would have
said so we can discuss with the
maintenance team how we can improve that
level of service and try to reduce the
um the problem time clearly if it's
raining for a few days then the problem
won't be there that's quite clear
um but it's it's on those long hot dry
days then we just need to keep
monitoring it more closely and and get
some good feedback and actually respond
to it rather than say we're not there to
next week so I'm happy to put my
question a bit of report back on hold
until we see how things have gone you
know given your comments yeah you know
thanks Russell
um
right
um Lobby do you think we've got a
meeting on the 20th or cluster meetings
on the 20th if you wanted to know the
view report back from Russell you can
work there quick I'm sure
Mr chair I'm happy just to see if let's
let's get on and just put a bit more
right push against a bit harder and see
how we see how we deliver it because
we won't be in too much financial
trouble I don't think all right I've
given five minutes to think about what
the answer he gave me about Steve Street
which is yeah still unhinging me a
little bit
um when we hit Russell when we had the
diversion last time that went through
Bay Road uh one of the things that the
community throughout which I thought had
some Merit but it was too late in the
process to get it done with why don't
you have an AEM one way and a PM the
other way so people coming in from
otatara in the morning get access and
then at midday you change it over and go
back out because probably 80 or 90 of
the traffic will be in those two periods
of going those two directions
and some of the other implications I got
last time right there was people
dropping the kids off at the
kindergarten early in the morning by the
time they went around Bay Road
physically couldn't get to work on time
they had jobs that prescribe certain
times and certainly I got some feedback
from the Emergency Services as well
because we've got 30 police out there uh
living without a turret and so it's
quite a big Community as you know of
about 4 000 vehicle movements a day so
it's significant I just don't understand
why we wouldn't consider that alternate
so if you come in in the morning it's 8
to 12 or whatever it's midnight till
midnight till midday is coming this way
and going back up the other way and how
appropriate signs to say hey if you're
coming in and it's the wrong time you go
down Curran Road or you go back back
through the city up through Bay Road
so just some ideas on it so Mr what
we've tried to do is for consistency so
that if you do know where you're going
you're going because if you're five
minutes later your watch is five minutes
I can just imagine you get there and
you're saying well no it's still five
five two and I'm coming through
um to be fair we've had some people who
didn't always believe they weren't
supposed to be going in that direction
anyway so I would think from a traffic
perspective it would have a degree of
um concern to actually rotate it
we have thought about during that during
the time whether or not we could run our
traffic signals the ceiling will be a
relatively short short activity and we
are trying to do it straight after the
break so that it actually has the
minimum of impact because there's still
quite a few people away yes it will have
an impact but it's something of a
reasonably short duration it's and and
we can suggest that to our contractors
but I and would anticipate that we
wouldn't necessarily think that would be
probably best traffic management
practice it's better to be consistent in
in terms of security from from my
experience yeah my experiences that we
don't get the consistency I've copped
quite a few biking through there when it
was closed off last time quite a few
people coming through that weren't meant
to be there predominantly younger people
um and they just come down that way
anyway there's not much you can do about
them
um when you say it's a short period of a
sailing what are we talking about I
think that
suggestions of days long okay but it's
could conceivably be less than that
subject to the way things go it's fine
thank you and it is only for the um
daylight hours when they're doing it so
it's not as if it's going to be so so
when when environment South and finished
their project are they going to cut
across your UCLA knowledge at the idea
once again it's a great question it's
something I really would like to make
sure that we've looked at this the state
of the road and we don't believe that we
can wait effectively another 18 months
before it um can be sealed so we intend
to seal the road and stop back from
where they're going to work so it is
actually quite a deliberate action and
it's something that we've really wanted
to make sure that's really really clear
that says that
um this is not a mistake we have to seal
it and then they have to actually deal
the piece in the middle the only reason
if it's sealed through the middle is if
it's easier for the contractor and it's
of very low cost to actually seal
through so it's something that we have
thought long and hard about whether we
could delay it and we can't
so so just what happens when the when
the artwork that's going up the cultural
artwork is going on will that be
completed by then
here we are working closely with them to
coordinate all of those things because
they are the three the other three
actions that are currently the artwork
the ceiling because the artwork has some
other I guess
um traffic related issues that we put
the cyclist and how do you manage them
so there's a whole lot of things that
are going on there that the team are
working closely together with to
minimize any impact because we're quite
aware of the concerns
okay Alan and then Darren
um yeah Russell Richard I've lived there
for 35 years or more I've seen the road
sealed I don't know maybe half a dozen
times and they've never once ever closed
the road or they felt they need to close
the road do you find now that just
because you did it that last time that
this is an easier option for you because
if you put traffic lights there and that
they were going to hold people up
wouldn't them people voluntarily choose
to go the other way if they thought they
might be held up
I mean what's changed so much that you
have to do it now and it's never been
done before
some of the new some of the new traffic
management from a safety aspect what the
contract is seeking to we've thought
long and hard whether or not we can
manage with with Travis singles and the
length of cues but we did see I guess
that an avoidable situation a couple
weeks ago where the traffic did back up
and that's the sort of thing you could
get but I accepted after Christmas that
the
um the traffic flows are less
um
something that we believe the contractor
we and the contractor think that that
solution we're proposing is is the
safest solution
and it's a it's once again it's a
relatively short issue
Darren thanks to you I was going to ask
Russell about the duration but he has
answered it but it is worth drawing back
out
the length or lack thereof because I've
watched these resealing Crews and
they're absolute machines so they've
allowed four days maximum and I imagine
they would have to be pretty wet they'll
do it in two to three
right no fair comments
um
Russell
um other topics here we've done the uh
we've done the beach
capacity is
that's about it nothing sorry Mr chi I
think it's worth noting that we've got
in there that the D Street
um stormwater renewal pipe is actually a
pipe that goes from Herbert Street
through the bohopo river
on D Street
it will be a reasonably difficult
traffic related issues and we shouldn't
underestimate the disruption that will
start
to be well have to be well managed by
the contractor I'll put that in the in
that context so I guess it's just really
alerting councilors to the fact that
that's going to start in the near future
um and and the other one was that um we
last week had a issue with one of our
brainstorm pipelines and what's been
managed from the operational team and we
still got some a couple of little things
but I guess that's the uh
the beauty of a looking at the new
pipeline which is actually will reduce
the impact of what we've had last week
but it also shows that having a full
duplicate line which is something more
recently that Council has invested in
has meant that we are able to maintain
continue to have good supplies of water
available
um slightly different risk but it's
certainly manageable operationally
foreign
can I just say that I like the visual at
the end because it and just in that
summarized so much
of the work that goes and we take for
granted
and probably the public does as well and
to see it just
as part of our roadmap to Renewal as
part of the road works as part of roads
in general
really really clever use of graphics and
information so I thank you for that
because it
after reading everything else it was
quite refreshing
thanks very much for the feedback um
it's Mr Nolan and his team that need to
take full credit for that um
let's have to lean to the side and
um yeah I agree it's it's a good way to
represent
The Works that are that go on as Bou
behind the scenes that we don't
necessarily see um it's the things that
are keep the place ticking
okay I'll be just in relation to the
white waste net joint Waste Management
agreement review
um
and I know Aaron's not here but um
first question I guess is who's doing
the review
do you know that Russell um Mr Nolan
unfortunately is sitting here and being
to be able to hopefully be able to help
advantage of you being here yeah if
you'd like to
come up and grab a grab Russell's
microphone
uh Mr chip
um in answer we're just going to market
now we've we've approached uh for uh
people to uh come through but we're
re-evaluating how we go to markets at
the moment
so through YouTube I guess I guess one
of my concerns about this is is that
we've got two layers of wasting it one
of the the staff layer for what I've
been working one as a governance layer
and I'd like to think that before we got
to the staff level that we we'd do the
governance one first because clearly in
my discussions recently within the last
two weeks with SDC
they um while they have the overarching
goals that are in this report about
being consistent and dealing with waste
they're very much on the recyclables
contract want us to take the lead and
for them to still be a supplementary
contract so that doesn't quite fit
without that framework of all the other
contract and work we do so I'd like to
think that if we're reviewing that the
review should be at the governance level
first
okay that how can you answer can you
answer that
um yes this review uh does look at the
governance structure as well yeah well
what I'm suggesting is instead of having
staff members who sit at the second tier
layer of waste net which is the where
the staff connect giving us advice on
what they think the governor's area
should be maybe the governor's area
itself should give some steer to to the
uh more of the operational side of waste
net to say hey this is what we want is
what we don't want
well I guess are you able Peter are you
able to answer where
waste knit currently sits at this minute
in the new trinium
um
from a governance point of view yeah so
in April 28th of April this year there
was a waste there was a governance
meeting and where the councilors on the
executive agreed that we would go
forward with the review to look at the
status of the waste net agreement and it
and how it's uh how it operates uh
currently as it's moved through because
it's 11 years old now so it you know it
certainly needs needs to be looked at I
know I agree with mayor Clark that it
needs to be looked at the governance
level and that's certainly um a big
component of the review
right because obviously we've got some
key things with waste minimization at
the moment the current waste
minimization plan and it's in its
summary or introduction actually says
that
we're in limbo now
in June this year we saw seven hundred
thousand dollars of rates increase due
to
us sending more to landfill and the
increased emission trading scheme taxes
and stuff now obviously this is a
reasonably urgent how soon can we
um we expect
something that'll get us up and running
to to Really address a lot of these
issues especially glass diversion stuff
like that sure so in relation to to the
review of the Wasteland agreement we're
aiming to go to market uh this month and
have the review finished by 31st of
March next year
31st of March
okay
um
certainly in my discussion with SDC they
wanted the governance group set up much
earlier than it
um and they've spoken to Gore as well
and the new meal there is really Keen to
get back into more of a governance group
Arrangement instead of just having the
contracts that we've got at the moment
which is our Primary in SDC being a
supplementary Cadre well I see actually
I mean speaking as cheer and with with
your
um sort of acceptance as mere there's no
reason why the chair of each uh the
chair of infrastructure of each uh ta
along with the mayor couldn't meet
informally to to actually discuss ideas
and that way you can hit the ground
running that's true yeah I think that's
that's can be done without and then we
can receive the review in March but I I
think you did right we need to you know
meet as soon as possible so that's
that's good any other any other
questions regarding the activities
report
oh just just one issue and it's not
really on the report but I I can't find
another opportunity to flag it when
we're at the Mirai recently in love
um we had a brief presentation about the
cultural artwork that's going along
stair Street which is really impressive
and I had some chance to talk to the
Carver which was really interesting and
we got talking about the um The Whale's
Tale that's it's earmark for Android
parade which is on the corner as you're
going into the airport and I just
flagged with him the idea of why
wouldn't you put that whale's tail out
um this side of the airport entrance
somewhere where you could one have a
backdrop that when you look at it you
saw the water out down the Estrella it
was first thing but everybody is going
to and from not just over Tower but out
to the beach and other places would see
it as well as the tourists coming in and
out as opposed to the only people who
will see that will be those who've came
to going to the airport and he was open
there but I didn't know from there how
we got onto that where where that would
go and who'd make the decisions and
where there was some chance to maybe
reconsider that Russell can you speak to
that
are you going to say that's a really
good question
hi Mr chair
um my understanding was that the project
team for stead Street had consulted with
the local rinaka about
um that project and I would need to
follow up and actually check
the place why the placements were there
so
Mr chair yes
to his worship
this is part of a whole cultural
narrative strategy we were asked to
provide we were commissioned basically
to provide an artwork for that
particular location and that is the
design and narrative that was
considered to be appropriate for the
entrance way to the city given that our
narrative deals very strongly
on the imagery of a whale's tail it is
part of the runicus
uh branding it has been part of the
Southern minihiku branding
for longer than any of us have been
alive probably the best part of
150 years so that is the reason is it
because of the particular meaning of
marihiku which is the fluke of the whale
therefore that is the choice of the
design that is we were asked to put a
work in that particular location it was
designed for that location to tell the
story
moving it to elsewhere would change the
narrative it wasn't an accident it was
quite deliberate
Mr mirazette answer your question no it
doesn't really
um look we did the asking of Evie in
first place so I understand that that
was our location was our choice and
asked him for some input into what would
be appropriate there
and and I'm not trying to change in any
shape form the design work or anything
like that I'll just wondering whether we
get the best value
location-wise by having it there which
is a very restricted audience I guess
one of the better words but that's okay
if it's not to be it's not to be yeah
that's fine okay
right
um no more questions on the activities
report
the recommendation is that we
receive the activities report and also
confirm
that
the infrastructure committee chair
Russell you need to enlighten me on this
is uh
can prove the council submission is that
the previous one
hello Mr chair what we propose is that
we will prepare a drafts submission for
your consideration to support your Tay's
interim speed management plan which is
included in the activity which includes
the three schools which the their speed
management plan is really about this
school is not necessarily about reducing
any other state always speeds okay and
just following on with the need for
spelling Corrections
refers to me as kahia which is a black
knight and some video game called The
Witcher
which I don't think is correct so yeah
spelling mistake yeah
exactly
no that's cool so anyone uh can I have
something to move those three three and
two thank you Leslie seconded partner
and put those
against that is carried thank you
Russell and Peter oh Peter do you want
to touch on the per capita thing is that
right or
yeah and we just asked a question on uh
kilograms per capita for the waste
um
in reference to what
yeah
for the 21 22 uh yeah
there was uh 616 kilograms 660 616. uh
six one six yeah kilograms per capita
however with diverting uh some recycling
that got down to 430 kilograms of waste
per capita
okay now's not the time to bring it up
but I will be asking why in June we were
hit with rates increases
for an increase on the 650.
um it just doesn't quite make sense but
that is a separate issue not to be
discussed discussed here
thank you for that
four three four three zero
[Music]
thanks Peter okay
um right that is the end of the public
uh part I got one quick question yeah
um the inner city Christmas lights and
decorations we know they programmed to
put up because we're only a matter of
days out from Christmas aren't we
uh
actually Alice was speaking to Santa the
other day but I don't know I'll get Mr
Pearson
foreign
this year we plan to just continue with
the Christmas trees not put the lights
up there's a number of the strings that
aren't available to us but I suggest
we're going to get the best value by
actually considering something in the
midwinter and using them through there
so
right does that answer your question
Alex just to follow on from there we
know the strings be going back up
um the ones and the ones in toaster it
won't be but the ones in D Street will
be available after much of the
construction is finished
I actually never really quite understood
that answer are we saying that Christmas
is canceled this year for uh yes yes
we've got trees
we have six Christmas trees we put
around around the city that we we
decorate and the lights
um are more difficult to put up at this
time of year with the with the bits and
with the stuff that's going on the city
center so I'm suggesting once again that
it's actually probably get the best
value for the lights out during the
winter time when they actually are
usable
right I'm getting a rear and then Alex
and then Ella I'm just seeking
clarification so you just said that the
taste Street strings are not going back
up that's correct what's the reason for
that that's part of the new development
I guess the poles that support it have
been changed and we can't support them
there
so we'll be adding in the first block I
only have Thai street is it all that's
correct there's two strings down this
end yes
sorry um Alan who's next I'm just
wondering Russell if I you know drive
down D Street I still see a lot of we
only had about four strings on each
Street and and those strings go right
down past H and J SMS
so I'm just and then right down D Street
they go all the way down to sort of
pretty much that's pastry that's great
there's um why couldn't we have
Christmas lights on no strings
her mom's suggesting that that we just
don't put them up this year but we put
them up in the summer in the winter
times I don't like that idea okay Alex
Nigel Tom
thank you Mr chair
might I suggest that we put them up for
matariki rather than just Midwinter that
was what I was anticipating we would use
them for
the little snowman and things I mean as
much Tom I've got Nigel next sorry in
the interests of Santa uh
there's 48 trees at the stadium there's
four million lights
so look if you're missing that piece
just at the moment come down come down
to home and be a part of it Santa's
there the reindeer there
lots of trees and there's lots of lights
and I'm sure Russell going forward if
there is some spear string lights we can
string them up coming into Surrey park
because we're happy to be the home for
Christmas just in the interim period all
right so come on down be part of
something special
oh Tom
so through your chair I mean it seems to
me unacceptable
on the 5th of December as a consequence
of a question asked by a counselor we
heard about this for the first time
I mean I'm assuming that it was not put
to cancel before the last election so
um that decision which seems to me the
sort of thing that counselors are
inevitably going to be asked about
with the only reason that we really know
that is because somebody asked a
question I talk and I I really think we
should have been informed about that but
I'm not informed we should have been
asked about that properly
yeah and I imagine this is part of the
wellbeing committee
[Laughter]
no no that's okay look look I mean it's
yeah it's an operational thing there
means I can see the winter thing making
a lot of sense
um
it's probably too late to be pushing
Russell
to putting the lights up but we should
do some PR on us we should take Nigel's
suggestion and say hey look while we've
got the inner city development going on
it's not so easy to put them up
um and leave it to that if that's our
decision but we should get on the front
for that not wait till we get a hold of
the trolls asking us why we're not
putting lights up and how mean-spirited
we are and and say that in the interim
is an interim measure that we've got a
whole lot down the stadium that's free
to get in that look it is free isn't it
Nigel oh it's each and every day it does
it is free so I can leave that with you
Mr Mayor I yes I can do something if
that's the wish of council but I'm not
sure it is a whistle Council to not put
the lights up to be helpful to canvasate
I think
because there's nothing Russell can't do
if we give him the right direction
you mean okay like I'm gonna take Alex
and then I'm gonna pause okay
in addition to that um I believe we're
the city center coordinator will have um
Christmas in there what would do
Christmas markets and Christmas in the
City and that sort of thing
um with our new streetscapes and such do
you know if that's planned yeah
not sure that's not
I don't think Christmas in the Park
because it's something that we've ever
been responsible for but we have had
Chris in a city Christmas markets and um
as part of the inner city activation now
that we do have part of the street open
it would be helpful to know if we are
activating that area across Christmas
if we could find that out that would be
awesome
okay right I'm going to end the
discussion on the Christmas lights and
we're going to leave it for the mayor to
talk to Russell and if something happens
then something happens but um
we're sending a delegation to China yeah
okay
sorry uh true
not about lights but I do have an answer
for you on Dust in houses oh
setbacks are not created for this
specific issue as such and there are
there is no setback provision in rural
areas it is down to the building owner
to cite the building taking into account
the potential for dust nuisance okay I
thought there might have been something
under Health but no thank you for that
Drew they would notice the gravel road
when they're buying the house
potentially okay right thank you
everybody that is the end of the public
session because I have someone move
we're going to be but uh uh from the
committee yes Evelyn and second to
Darren I'll put that motion all those in
favor
before